[Music]
a san diego mother blasting her local
board of supervisors for hurting small
businesses
and maintaining some of the country's
strictest mask mandates
long after she says the emergency is
over
we are no longer in a state of emergency
just months ago i could walk through
target
sipping a starbucks coffee but the
independent coffee shop owner around the
corner who supports four
children was told not only to close but
threatened with
that mother of four melissa o'connor
joins us now good morning melissa
good morning good morning what took you
to that point
you know i speak for a lot of other
people in my state
i'm sure new york and other parts of the
country
everybody's experience over the last
year and a half has been
really different and i want to be
sympathetic to that
i'm not coming from a place of just
thinking about myself
um as you just saw the clip where i
talked about the coffee shop owner
but just what we've endured
in this state as parents has been
so difficult um and
i feel like they have us right where
they want us because
we were in such a grind trying to make
every day happen with small kids you
know either
juggling working from home and
figuring out how to you know get them
set up on a computer to do distance
learning and i have
a baby and a three-year-old at the time
they were climbing all over my son's
computer when he's
just and they shut down our playgrounds
and
the beaches libraries just
opened here so we had little resources
and is fighting about it and it just
gets to be too much and so you know our
board of supervisors
they're the ones who implement all of
our public health mandates
and they just start a meeting in person
and enough is enough
i showed up to represent um moms across
america
who are fed up with all of these rules
melissa it's crazy
even if you're vaccinated you still have
to wear a mask
in your area on public transport or
transportation indoors in k-12
schools health settings and nursing
homes detention facilities
homeless and emergency shelters and i
look at that video of you
i know how hard it is to be a mother a
mother of
four you had to get all those kids
dressed in their car seats
drive to that meeting you're very
passionate about this and i know that
you're a big supporter
of sharon mckinnon she started the let
them breathe
and she's taking legal action what do
you how do you see this playing out in
san diego when are they going to
lift all these restrictions yeah thank
you so much for bringing up her
organization
because i am i guess
is this how this works in america like
you have to
sue people to get your rights back
what's been happening is completely
unconstitutional so
her organization is funded by parents
were funding a lawsuit against the state
and to say these mandates aren't lawful
and they've gone on long enough i mean i
think
i feel comfortable being on national
television saying
we shouldn't have our kids and masks
yeah well thanks for standing
in masks thanks for standing up for our
kids and for these small businesses
you're right you told our producers
target made 15 billion yet the small
business had to close
thank you so much keep fighting more fox
and friends coming up
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now